Ultimately the ability
to learn a language is...
it still comes down to the three
keys that I referr to so often.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here.
Today I want to talk about the role
of talent in language learning.
Uh, remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe and click
on the bell for notifications.
So if any of you out there have
learned even one or more languages
to a fairly decent level, you have
undoubtedly had people tell you,
you have a talent for languages.
And the people who say this to
you are typically people who
don't speak other languages.
Someone who already speaks two or
three languages is unlikely to say
that because they know that learning
another language takes a lot of effort.
So the typical person who says you have
a talent for language either hasn't put
a lot of effort into learning a language,
or is stuck with a method of language
acquisition which isn't very efficient.
They go to the library language, Spanish
class, three times a week or something.
Uh, people who are successful at
language learning they typically
will do a lot of listening and
reading and put a lot of effort.
Uh, I mean, very few people will do what
I do, which is to get up every morning
and listen to whatever language I'm
learning and listen an hour a day while
working out, while cleaning up, uh, and
do a lot of reading and put in an hour
or two every day into language learning.
Few people do that.
Uh, so typically people who say you
just have a talent for language, uh,
are kind of trying to justify the
fact that they haven't been willing to
put that degree of effort or to look
for more efficient ways of learning.
But is there a talent
for language learning?
I think it's possible that there
are varying degrees of ability
to learn another language and a
number of things influence that.
First of all, the more languages
you know, the better you
become at learning languages.
Your brain is more flexible.
You are more open to new
sounds, new structures.
You don't resist the new language.
Uh, you're more confident
that you can do it.
You have some ideas of, of methods
that, for language learning,
that work at least for you.
So you're a better language learner.
So, so that's obviously going
to influence, but that's not
so much talent as, as ability.
It's not sort of an inherent
talent for language learning.
Uh, another thing that influences
our ability to learn is the degree to
which we're exposed to the language.
So if you go to Sweden where
kids television is in English and
listen to English language, uh,
you know, pop music and so forth.
They have so much exposure to English
before they start that in Sweden
just about everybody speaks English.
So is it that the English...
that the Swedes have some
gene for language learning?
I don't think.
And it's similar in other places where
people are exposed to a lot of languages
like in Singapore or apparently in
Ethiopia, although I've never been there.
So the amount of exposure you
get influences your ability to
learn a language, but that's not
necessarily the same as talent.
Uh, I think ultimately the ability to
learn a language, it still comes down to
the three keys that I referr to so often.
The attitude of the learner,
time spent with the language
and the ability to notice.
And I'll leave a link to a video
that I just did on the subject of
noticing and language acquisition.
But obviously attitude.
As I said, someone who's learned a
few languages has a positive attitude.
They think language learning
is worthwhile doing, worthwhile
spending a lot of time at.
They're confident that
they will achieve success.
Typically they like the
language they're learning.
So these attitude factors are
much more important than any
potential differences in talent.
Uh, the same with time, you can't learn
languages without putting in the time.
Some people are willing, more
willing to put in time than others.
Uh, noticing is something that comes with
a good attitude and putting in the time.
So, you know, my point really is
it's a bit like the discussion
can older people learn languages?
Like here I am 75, uh, is a 20 year
old a better language than I am?
No, it doesn't really matter.
It doesn't really matter.
We can all learn.
Even if we assume that some people
are more talented or that a 20 year
old is better than a 75 year old,
it doesn't mean that a potentially
less talented person can't learn.
Theoretically less talented person
has a good attitude, is interested
in the language, likes the language,
believes that learning the language
is worthwhile doing, believes
they're going to get there, believes
in the method they're using.
Uh, and if that person puts in the time
and then develops, you know, is really
keen on noticing what's happening in
the language, that person will learn.
And if that person is slightly less
talented, talented than someone
else, maybe not as good at imitating
the sounds or, or at remembering
vocabulary, that person will still learn.
Uh, so to tell someone who has
learned three or four languages, oh,
you're just talented in languages.
Um, that's a cop-out.
That very person who was saying, oh,
you're just talented, like I'm not.
You are.
If they were to have a positive attitude,
put in the time, be, be motivated
to notice what's happening in that
language to accept that language rather
than resist, that person will learn.
And if you take 10 people, some
will learn better than others.
Some will pronounce better than others.
Some will, uh, speak better than others,
but those differences are relatively small
compared to the differences that come
from the sort of differences in attitude,
differences in time spent, differences
in methods used for language learning.
So therefore I would disagree.
Talent as an important
consideration in language learning.
Uh, it's something that even
if there are differences, we
can't control those differences.
But what we can control is our attitude,
the time we spend and to some extent
flowing from that, our ability to
notice what's happening in the new
language and therefore to acquire that
language or several more languages.
So there you have it, that's my take
on, on talent and language learning.
And I suggest you have a  look at
the video I did on noticing, and
I'm look forward to your comments.
Thank you, bye for now.